EGYPT, WE'LL GO WITH YOU FIRST.
LADIES FIRST.
>> WAIT A MINUTE, THIS IS A
SETUP!
>> Larry: THAT IS BEER PONG SO
WE'RE GONNA DO THE FRAT
QUESTION. YOU HEARD IN THE NEWS,
SAE, THE RACIST FRAT --
>> KIND OF REDUNDANT, ISN'T IT?
>> Larry: WELL DONE! AND THERE'S
THE GUYS AT PENN STATE
WITH NAKED PICTURES AND WILL
FERRELL CAME
OUT AND SAID WE SHOULD GET RID
OF FRATS ALTOGETHER.
YOU'RE A BIG PARTYING FRAT GUY,
ROBERT, WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> I SAY FRATERNITIES ARE
ELITISTS, EXCLUSIVE AND THERE IS
NO EDUCATIONAL FUNCTION.
GET RID OF THEM COMPLETELY.
>> Larry: GONE?
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
>> IF YOU GET RID OF SORORITIES
AND FRATERNITIES, NO ONE GOES TO
SCHOOL ANYMORE, QUITE HONEST.
THAT'S THE BEST PART OF COLLEGE,
THE WHOLE EXPERIENCE.
YOU SHOULD'NT THROW OUT THE
WHOLE BATCH OF APPLES BECAUSE OF
ONE BAD APPLE.
THE REALTY IS THERE ARE A LOT OF
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITY THAT
ARE EXEMPLARY.
THEY DO GREAT COMMUNITY SERVICE,
THROW GREAT PARTIES --
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
LET ME JUST SAY THAT FOR THE
LAST 40 YEARS THAT I HAVE BEEN
IN AND AROUND UNIVERSITIES,
EVERY YEAR OR TWO THERE IS A
SCANDAL AND THERE'S AN APOLOGY
AND THESE PRIVILEGED ELITE
PEOPLE COME OUT AND DO PRESS
CONFERENCES AND THEY SAY NEVER,
NEVER AGAIN, AND THEY DO IT
AGAIN!
>> Larry: IT'S A NEW BATCH OF
DICKS COMING IN, THOUGH.
>> IT'S FRESH DICKS.
WHY AM I THE ONLY WOMAN ON
THE SET HERE!
>> HOLD ON A MINUTE.
I THINK YOU'RE BOTH RIGHT.
I DON'T THINK THEY DO AS MUCH
GOOD AS EGYPT SAYS BUT I DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BAN THEM.
BUT I DON'T THINK THEY DO A LOT
OF GOOD.
BANNING STUFF IS A BAD PRACTICE
JUST BECAUSE A COUPLE OF
PEOPLE -- IN OTHER WORDS, WE
HAVE THE KKK IN AMERICA, WE
DON'T BAN THAT.
>> THOSE GUYS ARE BIGGER DICKS!
>> Larry: K.K.K. HAS A LOT OF
GOOD PARTIES, TOO!
(LAUGHTER)
>> LARRY, I'M GOING TO DISAGREE
WITH THAT.
AS A JEW, I DON'T GO TO THOSE
PARTIES.
>> Larry: WERE YOU EVER IN A
FRAT OR ANYTHING?
>> I CONSIDERED JOINING A FRAT
WHEN I GOT IN COLLEGE.
THEN I HUNG OUT WITH TEN GUYS
AND WE HAD OUR OWN CREW
>> THAT'S CALLED A GANG.
WELL, WE DID OUR STUFF
UNDERCOVER.
>> AGAIN...
BUT I WILL SAY YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE BAD AND GOOD FRATS.
DID YOU SEE OLD SCHOOL?  I
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BAN THEM.
JUST MAKE THEM MORE DIVERSE.
THAT WAY, IF THEY DO SOMETHING
RACIST, THE BLACK GUY GOES, WHAT
THE (BLEEP) YOU SAY?